in this video i'm going to introduce you
to two units of measuring length
the first is the inch which you might
have heard about and you're probably
thinking how long is an inch
well if you're familiar with a quarter
a quarter looks something like this
you see george washington on it
a quarter is almost an inch so an inch
might be
something
like that one
inch
another way to think about it is when
i'm looking at my thumb and i'm a grown
man at least physically
my thumb
is about
my thumb is about two inches in length
so my thumb
is about two inches in length
one
inch
and two
inches
depending on your age if you're watching
this and let's say you're eight years
old seven or eight years old your thumb
might be
closer to an inch or maybe a little bit
over an inch
now the other unit of measurement you
can view it as a bunch of inches put
together and if you put 12 inches
together you get what is known as a foot
a foot
now the word foot is used for many
things in our language including for our
individual feet or or the things at the
ends of our legs
and i believe i'm not sure where the
unit of measurement of the foot came
from but they might be related because
actually my foot is almost a foot and in
fact my shoes
and i wear a size i wear a men's size 10
and a half
my sneakers that i wear are almost
exactly
are almost exactly one foot now clearly
and you could sometimes see it written
as ft short for foot
now clearly not everyone's foot is a
exactly a foot because everyone's feet
and shoes have different lengths but
that gets you a sense of how large a
foot is another way to think about it
and as i just mentioned if you put 12
inches together you get one foot
12
inches
equals
equals 1
foot
so let me give you
some some objects and i want you to
pause the video and think about would
you measure them in foot or inches or
whether the measurements themselves are
sound like measurements in feet or
inches
so
if i give you a piece of paper a regular
piece of paper
kind with the holes on it and the nice
lines
so a piece of paper right over here
if i were to tell you that the height of
this paper is 11 something would that be
11 inches or 11 feet
well if it was 11 feet that would be a
huge piece of paper that would be a
piece of paper taller than me that would
be more of a carpet than a piece of
paper so a piece of paper is actually a
standard piece of paper is 11 inches
tall
now if we were to go outside and play a
little basketball so this is the
basketball
this or that's the backboard and then we
have the hoop
the hoop
we have the net
and then
we have the post holding it up we draw
that in a different color so we have the
post
and this is a standard
nba basketball rim
how if i were to say it's 10 something
off the ground is that 10 inches or 10
feet
well if it was 10 inches it would be
very easy to dunk a basketball and
although it might be hard to fit the
basketball in the rim because if the rim
was uh
it might also be very very small that
would be more of a basketball goal for a
for an insect of some kind or for a very
very small mouse for normal human beings
the standard height of a basketball goal
is 10 feet
the one that they play with in the nba
it's at your school if you're a little
bit younger you might see a basketball
goal that is six feet or eight feet or
nine feet but the standard ones that the
professionals play with are 10 feet tall
now let me give you some things and i
want to decide whether it's better to
measure them with feet or with inches
so let's say that i have a swimming pool
say i have a swimming pool right over
here
and
that is the pool would it be better to
measure the length of this swimming pool
in feet or in inches pause the video and
think about that
well a swimming pool is fairly large it
is much larger than even a foot so you
think you'd want to measure if you had
to choose between feet and inches you
would pick feet and so
this would be a situation where that
pool might be say 75
feet long
now if you were measuring a the length
of
a mouse
this is a mouse right over here not a
not my best drawing of a of a mouse with
its tail
it's feet right over there would you be
best off measuring it in feet or inches
a small mouse a mouse that could fit in
your hand
well that's going to be a good bit less
than a foot so it makes sense to measure
that in inches i've seen mice that might
only be two or three inches long
so i'll leave you there hopefully that
gives you a rough sense of what an inch
is what a foot is how they're related to
each other and when you might use one or
the other